The primary flight controls are the ailerons, rudder and elevator.
Ailerons control roll about the airplane's longitudinal axis,...
...which runs through the nose and tail.
The ailerons are attached to the outboard trailing edge of each wing...
...and move in opposite directions from each other.
The rudder controls movement of the airplane about its vertical axis,...
...which runs to the top and bottom of the airplane.
This motion is referred to as yaw.
Elevator controls pitch about the lateral axis which runs through the wing tips.
In most small airplanes, the ailerons, rudder and elevators are connected...
...to the airplane's control wheels mechanically through cables and pulleys...
Secondary flight controls include flaps and trim.
Flaps extend from the lower surface of the wings, increasing lift and drag.
There are four common flap types:...
...plain, which simply angles downward on a hinge,...
...split flaps, which increase lift and drag more than plain flaps,...
...slotted flaps, which increase lift a great deal more than plain or split flaps...
...by allowing high-pressure air from below, up and over the flaps...
...and Fowler flaps, a type of slotted flap which extends rearward and downward.
Trim consists of a small tab attached to the primary flight control by a hinge.
Airplanes have roll trim, rudder trim and or elevator trim.
As the airplane is flown in different speeds and configurations,...
...it will tend to pitch, roll or yaw, requiring the pilot to place a continuous force...
...on the controls in order to keep the airplane in the desired orientation.
By using trim, the pilot is able to relieve these flight control pressures,...
...which reduces workload.